hey guys I'm we've seen announce wall
and we've been playing a whole bunch of
piranhas today so we've been playing the
Dominion mode which is a objective-based
capture the zone three zones yep a and C
your nice easy ones to get lots of
access points lots of different routes
to get yellow bow elevate linking top
bomb and their zone be in the middle
which is where it's popping off it's it
off the hook yep those minions and
creeps like AI fighting against each
other and then you get in the middle of
it and it's crazy so the gameplay
surprisingly deep I expected it to be
kind of like a hack and slash e-type
game with maybe some employees but their
God mechanic and the strike mechanic has
a lot of depth to it involves holding it
feels almost like just almost reaching
the point of clunky but no no yeah it's
kind of really weird to explain like you
old el L left trigger and you kind of in
your God's sake and then you flick the
right stick to kind of nullify your
opponent's attacks as they come in and
then in those in those similar states
use the other two bumpers too heavy or
might attack which sounds
straightforward but when you get in the
thick of it when it's 11 it's so
satisfying it's really great and it
generally feels like really deep and
tactical play and it does really 10
I think some of that maybe gets lost
when t11 baku sure yeah but it does you
do feel like though you can I felt
frustrated all the time when I was on a
2v1 scenario because it felt like I
there was nothing I could have done even
playing at my best you know there's a
little there's a lot of like depth in
and like you want to want to be one bite
yeah thank you very much focused in on a
character and trying to see if they're
moving their sword around to kind of
Perry and that kind of stuff but when
you go to people it's quite difficult I
almost felt like that was the point like
they want you to roll around in a like a
pair or group that's for me it does
totally promote playing with another
person and the best fits I found like
these great sort of opportune moments
where it's you versus two enemies and
like your body will come and just
totally save your ass yeah you know one
person down and you manage to resurrect
them on the battlefield and then you
know the Lord's completely changing your
favor so it's a game where so much
happens and so much comes up and there's
also things called feats which are sort
of these powers that you earn by playing
really well and it can be anything from
like an arrow Halestorm or just an arrow
or didn't feel yourself in your teammate
and it's a it's a game that's
surprisingly in dec and I really really
enjoyed it there's a lot of wrinkles
quit it feels quite similar it feels
like a cross between something like
punch out in there like single 1v1 fight
and bushido blade well you have that
kind of like control over how you swing
your sword there's a lot of wrinkles to
it and frankly I'm quite surprised at
how much I enjoyed it I had some amazing
clutch moment but one of my favorite was
when I was almost dead and the only
thing I could do was folks I decided I'm
just gonna focus on blocking because I
could see in the distance one of my
teammates running towards me I'm like I
just need to hold out long enough for
him to get here and I did it and that
guy came in and just come in with a grab
and pull the enemy away from me yeah it
was just a moment all like yes this is
amazing
in as well as a great mode for that
because not only is it first to a
thousand times when you hit a thousand
please for the up the enemy team losing
team starts to break and you don't
respawn yeah so it becomes this frantic
like just yes that's gravel to kill
everyone but you can still resurrect
people and you can let get your normal
state back by taking enough point back
off the other team which is kind of like
your honor uphill struggle but if you
really band together and you know
working a stick together a role in fact
use your abilities proper you can claw
your back and there is that kind of like
excitement of having it absolutely yeah
so we had a blast when it comes out
every 14th next year get it in mind for
your Valentine dates but for more on
product make sure to stay tuned to games
you